looks like that house supports saving
women's sports and so GOP reps lower the
boom on who's allowed in the girls
locker room
yesterday the house of reps approved a
bill barring trans athletes from
competing in women's sports though
they're still free to compete in jar
opening peeing for distance and hogging
TV remotes
during the news Leah Thomas said it felt
like she'd been kicked in the ball
the legislation championed by Republican
lawmakers and anyone who isn't brain
dead would prohibit biological males
from playing on girls teams at federally
supported schools the bill aims to
redefine sex as something that's solely
based on a person's reproductive biology
and genetics at Birth replacing the
definition of sex as something David
Angelo does twice a year
[Laughter]
if I'm lucky yes
participate in programs meant for women
and girls they're going to lose Federal
funding but NYC of course sex is defined
differently as something to be shared
between a teacher and a student foreign
no surprise the bill received zero yes
votes from house Dems that it's unlikely
to pass the democrat-controlled Senate
and even if it did the White House has
already said they'd veto it assuming of
course they could keep Joe conscious
long enough to do it
but it should be noted that although the
bill would ban men from playing against
girls it won't affect men competing in
wet t-shirt contests as long as they've
got the rack for it
so Dagan this actually has a weird way
of proving that like binaryism is just
built into our system that no matter how
absurd an issue is
there's going to be
two sides to it like for example so so a
republican says uh a woman has a uterus
you have the entire Democrats going no
no it's not it's weird how like
everything has to be binary with these
people why can't somebody on the
Democratic side go you know what they're
making us look like idiots not one not
one Democrat voter for this and some of
the caterwalling from the left was more
absurd than even
I could comprehend there was one
Democrat who said this debate has
traumatized trans kids no you have
traumatized kids yes by even telling
them about it yes as traumatic as
organized competitive team sports in
general for children again this focus on
Sports it's you know what tag is fun
when you're five but not running around
on a soccer field wants a bunch of
helicopter deranged dads screaming at
little kids slower score yeah I'm just
saying
too much Focus
too much focus on Sports for kids I
couldn't hit blind as a bat the side of
a bus with a baseball bat yeah when I
was a kid I agree with that right I had
too much sports with t-ball right
you know you can strike out in t-ball
what are your thoughts
uh look I I think that it's gotten a
little absurd the overuse of the
transphobia to shut people up because
you know I'm someone I think you have
One Life to Live whatever makes you
happy do it if you were born a man
living as a woman makes you happy good
for you
that having an issue with that is not
the same as saying hey if you go through
male puberty your body is going to be
different than someone who is born
female you might be better in the pool
due to your bone structure being
different and these different things
that's just scientific and to equate
that to being someone who hates trans
people or is transphobic it's completely
made the debate about something that it
shouldn't be and is actually stopping us
from having a real debate at all because
it's just these extremes and people
assume that someone thinks an extreme if
they have a question that's based on
science a lot of these athletic
organizations have sent limits on this
based on science or all of these
organizations just overrun with
transphobes yeah or is there maybe
something to the biological difference
if you're born one gender versus the
other one sex versus the other it also
is frustrating uh Kennedy because you
did bring up Title IX that this
basically reverses the initial belief in
Title IX that to protect women now this
says we're not the Democrat rats and
women in the Democratic party saying
we're not going to protect women but
also the bringing up of what Dagan said
whenever there's an argument they bring
up trans kids and you're trying to
figure out what exactly
a trans kid isn't a trans kid until they
make them one you know it's not it's
okay I I disagree with that a little bit
because I do think that there is such a
thing as gender dysmorphia of course and
I recently had brunch I'm not trying to
name drop with Caitlyn Jenner and we had
a great time and and she said that
I did oh well then he is a woman
but we had a very interesting
conversation about gender dysmorphia is
real there is also a very real
difference between sex and gender and
I'm glad that someone wants to codify
that because there are advantages that
you get when you go through puberty as a
male and if you're not going to protect
women then if I were a women's
volleyball coach at a college I would
just be looking for dudes in pink you
know and and maybe like the Harry Styles
influence guys and Pearls yeah like have
you ever thought about a D1 scholarship
everything's going to be paid for we
just need some some dudes
some people yes on the front line who
can Spike The Living Daylights out of a
ball and you know you get college paid
for that's a great if I were if I were a
guy
at school I would absolutely do that
movie script I can't get into call the
College of his dreams declares himself
non-binary gets a scholarship to play
volleyball like at Women's College way
to come up with a transphobic movie yes
but no no no no
I will cast only trans children
when you say cash you may cast a spell
on them yes
David
has Western razor sponsored any sports
teams have you shaven any athletes
I have to really rack my brain on that
one the last is so long yeah geez count
on the record did we have it
um
no well this is a uh it's a great third
wheel rail topic yeah but uh I'll tell
you the you know I guess I disagree
though sometimes that the idea that
biological male is Superior in sports I
mean just as someone when I was in gym
class you know we would we would pick
teams and
I was not you know picked before most of
the women you know I'll just tell you
right now
how to dispel some of that uh that dick
but I don't know I mean that just says a
lot about you I know as an individual
but you're right people are different
you were uncoordinated probably in poor
health
probably friendless very sickly very
sickly child no one wanted to be around
you I can imagine you being picked last
for almost everything yeah you've seen
you're still single right
no but oh God
yeah I mean it's weird so the other
thing is about this is it's like I don't
the Republicans this isn't going to be a
law what do you do it's kind of like the
country is imploding in a lot of
different ways right like kind of uh
this is a very to me a local issue like
it begins local maybe it's sport by
sport but the governing bodies of sports
need to stand
and protect female athletes you know
otherwise in gymnastics Simone biles
does really impressive stuff for women's
gymnastics and your friend Keith will
tell you that that is wrote that is very
basic in men's gymnastics so if if you
can and it is an individual sport as
well as a team sport and if you can get
more points with biological males then
why wouldn't you select not so the
individual sports whether it's swimming
gymnastics who cares they're the ones
who have to decide and in that Community
if they don't care that's fine that's
their decision but they have to grow a
pair as it were and make some of these
tough decisions all right we got to move
on hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else